jacques chirac poursuit sa visite au
chili la première d'un chef d'état
français depuis le général de gaulle en
1964 le président et son homologue
chilienne la socialiste michelle
bachelet ont affiché leurs convergences
jacques chirac souhaite renforcer la
présence des entreprises françaises dans
ce pays érigé en modèle économique sur
place le reportage de mémona hintermann
et robin teboul le palais de la moneda
symbole de la démocratie assassiné par
le coup d'état de pinochet en 73 jacques
chirac rend hommage au chili qui tourne
le dos à son passé
hommage à michelle bachelet la
présidente socialiste élu en janvier
elle porte avec chaleur les couleurs
d'un pays qui fait de la dignité humaine
une vertu cardinale de son gouvernement
aujourd'hui malgré leur puissance les
militaires chiliens sont rentrés dans le
rang et les femmes ministres sont aussi
nombreuses que les hommes
mon style de gouvernement est aussi
important que ce que je vais faire un
sit-in plus proche des gens plus direct
plus humain oman le choix ne peut pas se
limiter à un joie de sexe c'est d'abord
et avant tout un choix politique le
ministre de la défense michèle alliot
marie ne dit pas non à une femme
président pourvu qu'elle en est les
toffes michèle alliot-marie président de
la république qui ça peut marcher non
royal quelle différence entre les femmes
des hommes c'est qu'elles sont d'abord
le travail et ensuite à elle pense aux
échéances au moment où elles viennent et
non pas par antibes
pas de grands portraits signés véritable
clou du séjour une expérience pour le
président et pour beaucoup de ceux qui
l'accompagnent le frisson d'un voyage en
métro projet matériel installé par les
français cette atmosphère franche sans
doute avec la solennité accompagnant de
gaulle à 64 dernière visite d'un chef
d'état français à santiago
ce voyage de jacques chirac s'inscrit
dans un contexte nouveau
le continent sud américain tout entier
bascule de la démocratie qui donne enfin
aux plus pauvres
l'espoir d'une voix au chapitre ici au
chili comme au brésil
jacques chirac a fait l'éloge de deux
pays résolument engagés dans des
politiques de gauche comme s'ils
arrivaient presque en fin de mandat ses
propres promesses pour corriger la
fracture sociale en france ressurgit
c'est avec nostalgie le